there's a remote part of Asia where
prehistoric monsters still rule these
ferocious predators are so powerful they
kill creatures ten times their size
maybe the Buffalo senses it's being
watched
the real-life monster makes it smooth
we call this animal the Komodo dragon
it drawls with anticipation
the Buffalo escapes but the Dragons job
is done it needs just one bite to kill
soon the buffalos wounds are festering
within days a powerful infection
destroys its body and it dies
it's a puzzle scientists all over the
world are trying to solve
only one thing's for sure
it works
don't expect leftovers from this
gruesome feast almost everything is
eaten bones whose even hide
it's like a scene from the age of
dinosaurs but appearances are deceptive
for a lizard the Komodo dragon is a
relatively new arrival on the planet